in this quaint midlothian neighborhood
giving back isn't unusual
but giving thanks in this special way is
something new
anthony the awesome ups our ups driver
anthony is the most kind and caring
deliberate person i've ever met anthony
gaskin drives this route through
halsley almost every day
she
in many ways he's become like family i
joked with him
back in june that i was going to add him
to my christmas card list because i
actually do see him more than family
he's you know always
stopping saying hi how are you how is
your mom how is your dad
it's just what many say they've needed
over the past
year the kindness that he spreads is
just unreal and especially during this
difficult time
to have anthony around is just it's
truly amazing this overall personality
demeanor
is so contagious that he was just like
what we needed in 2020. this sentiment
inspired patti friedman to send an email
to her neighbors
just in my own situation of kind of
feeling lonely and
trying to get my feet on the ground that
that he was bringing such
joy into my life together they came up
with a plan
to line the streets and thank the humble
man
who's made 2020 a little brighter
watching the video footage
i have watched it probably way too many
times i've sobbed
many tears just watching it because he
is such
an amazing person his smile is
infectious apparently anthony's story
has had a similar impact around the
world
on the cbs 6 page alone it's reached
more than 35 million people
it was meant to be it was going to
happen one way or the other not shocking
to anthony's own colleagues and friends
we all felt the same way
and the community he so graciously
serves i
didn't think he would be that emotional
but when i like it always teared me up a
little bit when i saw him i was like
yeah
you definitely deserve it in every way
well it shouldn't come as a surprise
that anthony was a little too busy for
an interview this time of year
in fact his friends say he hasn't even
read over the messages that are pouring
in
from around the world reporting in
chesterfield county tracy sears
cbs 6 news